starting on time not Berkeley time I
just had a course that I'm teaching sort
of in conjunction with people at Harvard
and Columbia and bu and everybody has a
different start time Berkeley is
definitely the latest okay anyway hi I'm
chef egoless ER director here of the
Simon's Institute and as you know we
have dedicated to study the theoretical
pure science we have programs every
semester and this semester we have a
circuit or Bunco program and data
science program that's better going on
and many people here are participants in
this program and we have a beautiful new
initiative which is journalists and
residents where we host journalists for
one term who science journalists who can
teach us about how to communicate and
can learn from us some things to
communicate that a correct assessment of
the program and so far it's been
wonderful and I think that we are only
getting better because this time we have
today's speaker
Anil another swami my pronouncing it
well okay great and Anil is an
award-winning journalist and former
staff writer and deputy news editor for
the New Scientist magazine and he's been
a guest editor for the science writing
program at the University of California
Santa Cruz he organizing teaches an
annual science journalism workshop at
the National Center for Biological
Sciences at Bangalore India and he's a
freelance feature editor for the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Science frontmatter
and he's also written for nature
National Geographic news discover now
take a matte matter wall street journal
the UK literary review and we're
extremely happy to have him here and I
think you should all maybe you should
well they'll see you I guess when you
get up we you should all feel free to
talk to any hotel about your work and
he's a wonderful communicator and it's
such a pleasure to have him here and
he's gonna tell us about his new book
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You chef e for that introduction
lovely introduction thank you very much
it's a great pleasure to be here as a
chef II said I'm here as journalists in
residence for this semester at
assignments Institute and this talk is
going to be about this book through two
doors at once it's a story of quantum
mechanics told through the lens of one
single experiment and this book is
written for a lay audience and perforce
the talks that I've given on this book
have also been for our lay audience and
I suspect this is not the kind of lay
audience that has usually been my
audience so I suspect most of you know
your quantum mechanics pretty well so
but there might be a few people here who
may not so for at least so that I
address everyone I'll keep the level of
discussion as if it's for a lay audience
so I hope for those of you for whom this
might be old hat you will bear with me
the thing I really wanted to talk about
is how do you tell a story about quantum
mechanics given that nothing
particularly new has happened in the
last few decades that deserves yet
another book so there have been so many
books on quantum mechanics so many
popular books and so the challenge was
what first of all why did I even think
that it merited a book and the reason
was that I've been a journalist now for
about 18 years writing about physics
quantum mechanics and a lot of the times
you encounter physicists describing some
of the counterintuitive nature
counteractive counterintuitive things
about quantum mechanics and you're
struggling to then try and explain that
to your audience which is a lady though
and for instance you hear about things
like superposition quantum superposition
you hear that Oh
quantum systems can be in multiple
states at the same time an electron can
be in two positions at once what does
that mean or this idea of non realism so
the idea that in order
the idea that reality doesn't exist
until it is observed or until someone
makes an observation now this is the
kind of idea that's usually talked about
in the popular media quite a lot about
the nature of reality as described by
quantum mechanics this is in direct
contrast to the realist theories that
we're used to in physics which is like
if you take theories that describe the
way our planets move around the Sun
those theories are realist theories the
planets exist regardless of whether we
observe them or not we just happen to
find them exactly where our theories
tell us they will be which is not quite
the same with quantum mechanics but
again it was hard to understand what all
this meant yeah when you're trying to
describe it or nonlocality nonlocality
is the idea that if there is an event in
space-time here then it can influence
some other location in space-time which
is quite far away instantaneously or
faster than the speed of light now this
is in direct contradiction to the
principle of locality which underlies
classical physics for instance
Einstein's theories of relativity our
local theories which means that nothing
no influence can travel faster than the
speed of light but again quantum
mechanics seems to suggest that
nonlocality is woven into the fabric of
the universe of reality so all of these
concepts were there and I was struggling
to try and figure out how do you tell a
lay audience about these things without
waving your hands without just making up
words and metaphors but actually trying
to get at what this means in terms of
experiments or what the theory is saying
invariably the physicists would say oh
it's all in the math well of course it's
in the math but what does this mean and
that's when it struck me that there was
one way into this story which is to take
the example of the double slit
experiment and the double slit
experiment is an experiment that goes
back 200 years and it has been around
since then and forms quite the backbone
of the kind of experiments that are done
in quantum mechanics so the experiment
itself is very straightforward it's
actually so straightforward as
be silly which is that you take a source
of light shine it at an opaque screen
there are two slits cut into that screen
and the question we have to answer is
what do you expect to see on the other
side now this really depends on what you
think the nature of light is and in the
1600s and 1700 thanks to Newton we
thought that light is made of particles
so Newton has had his corpuscular theory
of light corpuscles meaning particles so
if light is made of particles then our
intuition says that this is sort of what
we should expect that the particle
should go through one slit or the other
slit and pile up behind the to open
slits and you know that's that right
this experiment of course was not done
in Newton's time it was done in the
early 1800s by physicists English
physicist named Thomas Young and when he
did the experiment this is what he saw
he didn't see two strips of light he saw
alternate bands of light and are here
the dark regions represent regions where
there is more light falling so that
think of that as a photographic plate
and you're seeing a negative so what
you're seeing is an interference pattern
you're seeing alternate bands of light
and dark and this was proof that light
acts like a wave so the wavefront of the
light hits the two slits and then from
each slit there's a diffraction pattern
so two new sets of waves start coming
out of the two slits they expand
eventually they interfere and when they
hit the photographic plate you're seeing
the interference pattern so the the
places where there's more light the two
sets of waves are lining up crest to
crest and you get constructive
interference and where you're seeing no
light you're basically the crests of one
set of waves and the troughs of the
other are lining up and you get
destructive interference so this was
fine the light as a wave idea was around
until throughout the 1800s with Faraday
and then Maxwell's theory of
electromagnetism magnetism all of this
went on to sort of both to this idea
that light is a wave right and light is
indeed an electromagnet
wave so this this was great until
quantum mechanics comes along so early
early 1900s Einstein was the first to
talk about the idea that light actually
there are certain situations in which
light has to be thought of as being made
of particles quantum mechanics showed us
that electromagnetic energy of which
light is a form of light is an
electromagnetic wave so light is
electromagnetic energy and that all
energy comes in quanta how you so energy
is quantized there is a point after
which you cannot subdivide energy into
any smaller units so if you take for
instance red light of one frequency then
there is a smallest quantum of red light
you cannot divide the quantum any
further so this quantum is indivisible
and it's called a photon of red light
right now the experiment becomes really
interesting now if you think of if you
think of a like I think this might yeah
so this is a red laser pointer imagine
that this red laser pointer is shooting
out one photon at a time if it was
shooting out one photon at a time you
wouldn't see it there but but if you
imagine if it was and you were aiming
this at the double slit so now you know
that your laser pointer is sending out
one photon at a time you're sending the
one photon at the two slits and now what
do you expect to see on the other side
imagine there's a photographic plate
that is slowly collecting these photons
one by one the photons might be coming
out one every ten seconds one every 100
seconds doesn't matter that they're well
separated in time so at any given time
there's only one photon in the apart is
what do you expect
again our classical way of thinking says
oh if I'm sending particles one particle
at a time on the other side I'm
detecting one particle at a time surely
this is what must happen I should the
photon should go through one slit or the
other slit and I should see just those
two strips of light well this is quantum
mechanics and of course that's not what
happens you get exactly the same
interference pattern except this time
the interference pattern builds up over
time right so previously you had a
flashlight or
a beam of red laser light you shown it
at the two slits and you got that
interference pattern immediately but now
you are exposing this photographic plate
to a number of photons say 100,000
photons that have gone through the
Devastator paratus one at a time you
know five seconds apart ten seconds
apart and you're still getting an
interference pattern so now the question
is what is interfering right because you
know you have sent in one photon you
know you're detecting one photon so what
is it that's interfering r24 is the
photon going through both slits and
interfering with itself well we know a
photon by definition is an indivisible
unit of energy you can't divide a photon
into two so again the question comes up
what what is interfering and the other
thing that happens is any given photon
out here does not you cannot predict
exactly where it will go on that
photographic plate it will end up in one
of those regions that eventually form a
band of light so it will end up in one
of those regions of constructive
interference but for any given photon
you can only calculate the probabilities
of where it will end up you can't say
exactly where it will go right so there
is some sort of randomness in
determinism to this process I just had
lunch with professor Robby with Kirsten
and he talked about randomness and I
think I realized that my ideas about
randomness may be completely off but I'm
gonna stick to what I thought I
understood otherwise I will be
completely confused but but there is
some notion of randomness here you
cannot really predict what exactly each
photon will do does the photon have a
trajectory like if I were to throw a
ball from here to the that end of the
room and I was very precise in how I
threw and if I knew all there was to
know about the ball in terms of the
forces acting on it the force of gravity
etc it would be very easy to predict
exactly where that ball will go here
you're shooting the photon you're
assuming that you know everything there
is to know about the photon and yet you
cannot predict where you go which means
that you cannot chart a trajectory for
it right and then what happens if you
were to try and see which slit the
photon goes through right again your
classical intuition is telling you that
the photon has to
through one slit or the other let's say
you came up with a mechanism whereby you
could figure out which little photon
goes through right and if you did that
hardly enough what will happen is you'll
get this pattern back so if you try to
collect which slit information if you
try to collect information about which
slater photon is going through the
interference disappears if you don't try
to see which set of photon goes through
then the interference appears right so
this is the essential experiment and the
whole book I realize that the entire
story of quantum mechanics all of the
conceptual difficulties that arise when
you look at the fundamentals of the
foundations of quantum mechanics can be
understood not answered yet but
understood in terms of this one
experiment so and this experiment has
been done over and over again and built
and has become more and more complex
over the years and it provided a perfect
having you for explaining these deep
conceptual issues that continue to
quantum mechanics so if if anyone tells
you that quantum mechanics is sorted out
a done deal don't believe them it's not
at the conceptual level it is fabulous
at making predictions probabilistic
predictions it is the most successful
physical theory we have there's no doubt
about it everything we're doing right
now our computers that you know all of
this works because we understand the
world quantum world you know in the way
we do with quantum mechanics but in
terms of what it actually tells us about
the nature of reality questions still
remain right so I I thought I'll take
this experiment and then start building
it up throughout the book so this became
kind of a pedagogical tool it was a way
to tell the story not just of one
experiment but of all the different
conceptual issues that really haunt the
foundations of quantum mechanics and and
if you ever go to a conference on the
foundations of quantum mechanics you
will see what I mean no one agrees I
mean there are there are these distinct
camps that are continually at odds with
each other and there is absolutely no
agreement as to the nature of reality by
nature of reality
when what one means is what is real what
exists
can we even say anything based on this
theory about what exists all these
questions are there right so what I did
was after in the book after starting
with an introduction that I just gave
you about the classical double slit
experiment I switched to talking about
the way this experiment is done in
laboratories so laboratories they work
on optical benches they use a very
particular kind of double slit
experiment and I just want to run
through a few iterations of these slides
because you'll see how simple this
experiment is and how many questions you
can ask based on this one small small
tabletop experiment so this is a source
of light which is hitting something
called a beam splitter a beam splitter
is simply a half-silvered mirror that
reflects half the energy of the light
falling on it and transmits half the
energy of the light any window is
actually any glass pane of glass is a
kind of beam splitter and almost every
piece of glass is transmitting some
light and reflecting some light this
just happens to be laboratory grade
mirror so it will precisely reflect half
the light that's falling on it and
transmitted half the light right now if
you just again take a you know regular
laser red laser and with a strong beam
and shine it how the energy of the laser
will go one way have the energy the
other way
now the same experiment done with single
photos you tune down the laser or you
can't really tune down a laser but let's
say you have some source of single
photons that is hitting this beam
splitter it now comes the question what
happens we know that a photon cannot be
divided any further so it's not like
this beam splitter is going to send half
the energy of the photon one way and
half the other way that can't happen
what happens if you do this is that the
photon is reflected half the time and
transmitted half the time so it becomes
a probabilistic thing now quantum
mechanics tells you that the photon will
be in one path 50% of the time and in
the other path 50% of the time right and
we can verify this if you were to put
detectors at the end of the two paths
which are photon detectors and you now
send ten
and photons into this part as one by one
on average you know d1 the one that is
at the end of the reflected path will
click saying oh you know ponder photon
and the other half of the time d2 will
click on average so 10,000 photons if
you send them in one by one into this
beam splitter 5,000 on average will go
one way 5,000 on average go the other
way you can now just change this
configuration a little bit this hasn't
changed at all compared to this all that
has happened is the path has been
extended all we have done is put two
mirrors at the you know at certain
points in the path and they're just
deflecting the beam at right angles and
they're still going to those detectors
d1 and d2 so again same thing if you
send 10,000 photons into this one by one
quantum mechanics says that half of them
will go one way half of them will go the
other way and B one is going to click a
50% of the time d2 will click 50% of the
time again the key here is that any
single photon you cannot say with
certainty what it will do you can only
talk in terms of are there's half the
chance it will go one way half the
chance will go the other way right but
on average you know it's it's split into
two not the photon but the number of
photons now you can do something very
interesting which is you put a second
beam splitter at exactly the location
where the two paths cross right so if
you go back to the previous one if d1
clicked you know if d1 clicked you know
that the photon took this path the
reflected path if d2 clicked you know
that it took the transmitted path
now let's say d1 clicked is there any
way to tell which path it took
yes it's impossible because the because
the photon could have come this way or
it would have come this way right so a
photon reaching detector D one could
have been reflected by the first beam
splitter and then transmitted next or
transmitted first and reflected next
right or the amazing thing that happens
when you put the second beam splitter
into this setup is that now when you
send 10,000 photons one by one into this
beam splitter if you try to calculate
based on our classical logic as to what
happens it will be wrong our classical
logic tells you that if 10000 photons
are sent into this setup one by one then
half will go this way and at then that's
at the second beam splitter again half
goes this we have goes this way and the
same thing happens with this path so
basically in the end you should end up
getting the same averages you should
still get 5000 going to d1 5000 going to
d2 this is quantum mechanics so that's
that's not what happens turns out that
all the photons as long as the path
lengths are equal as long as the path to
paths between the two beam splitters are
of equal length all the photons in this
case will go to d1 none will go to d2
right if I take this out
they split half go to D one half go to
d2 you should put the second beam
splitter in all go to D even none go to
d2 and why is that and this really is
just asking this question why takes us
to the heart of quantum mechanics right
and the reason is because the way the
math explains it and that and that's
where the interesting bit begins the way
the math explains it is you have to go
back to this figure let's now think of a
single photon going through this set up
the math says that the photon is
represented by the photon has a quantum
state the quantum state is given by what
they call a wave function is just a
mathematical abstraction and it's the
wave function that is made to evolve and
go through our go towards the two slits
a wave function is simply as you all
know it's just a function in
space in time so it tells you something
it has a value at every location in
space and time and that wave function
evolves according to something called
the Schrodinger's equation which is just
a partial differential equation I just
I shouldn't say just a partial
differential equation it's quite a
profound one but it balls according to
the Schrodinger equation so there's a
very it acts like a wave and so the
Steep of the photon north the photon
we're just talking of the mathematical
abstraction that represents the state of
the photon that abstraction is made to
evolve it hits the two slits exactly
like a wave diffracts two sets of waves
start coming out from the other side and
they expand and interfere and create an
interference pattern but this
interference pattern that's created is
of a mathematical abstraction right and
if you were to say what does that
represent well that's where the that's
where the mystery is right the the wave
function if you were to say what is the
value of the wave function the moment it
meets the photographic plate at a
certain location you can look at the
amplitude of the wave and the when you
square when you take the square of the
amplitude you get the probability of
finding the photon at that point it's
not telling you the photon is here it's
just give so the wave function is now
spread out like a wave and it has
different values at different points and
if you take the square of the amplitude
of that wave function wave function the
value of it at any given location you
get the probability of finding a photon
there if you were to measure if you were
to look for it right so which means that
the photon could be anywhere where there
is a nonzero probability along that
plane and if you were to measure it it
will appear or not appear at the point
where you choose to measure it and the
wave function just gives you the
probability of finding that and those
probabilities get borne out if you do
this experiment over and over again with
identically prepared photons with the
same quantum state so if you did if you
did 100,000 measurements just send the
photon it will turn out that the
probabilities that are given to you by
the wave function do get you know
manifested in the numbers of photons
that land on that photographic plate now
if you were to look at this setup now
it's much easier to understand what's
happening in terms of the wave function
as to why all of them all the photons
end up here and none go there the reason
is the the wave function of the photon
comes into the beam splitter at this
beam splitter the wave function splits
one component goes this way one
component goes this way remember this is
mathematical we are not saying that
something real is going through one path
and something real is going through the
other path mathematically part of the
wave function is going this way and it
comes here again gets split and goes
this way in this way the other other one
comes this way transmitted hits the
second beam splitter is again
transmitted or reflected so now if you
look at the wave functions that are
coming out of the second beam splitter
it turns out that one of the paths has
two reflections and two transmissions
right so the the path that is reaching
d2 the wave function could either be
reflected and then reflected again or
transmitted and transmitted so that the
wave that is transmitted twice is 180
degrees out of phase with the wave
that's reflected twice so one component
of the wave function is lagging the
other component of the wave function 180
degrees so the crests are lining up with
troughs and you get destructive
interference of the wave function here
you're getting constructive interference
of the wave function because it has one
reflection one transmission or one
transmission and one reflection the
waves are in sync and mathematically the
wave functions line up and you get
constructive interference right so if
you now ask what is the probability of
finding the photon here the wave
functions value is zero here here if you
take the square of the amplitude of the
wave function here you will get a
probability of one so in this particular
setup all of the photons go here none of
them go there right now the question is
what is this wave function is this real
you know what just went through both
sides we know that the photon cannot
split and go through both paths at once
but something did go through both paths
at once because otherwise how do you
explain interferes so these are the
kinds of conceptual questions that are
very easy to raise with this experiment
and then start talking about you know
how physicists are dealing with it or
what what they're trying to in terms of
alternate theories that are trying to
address some of these issues that crop
up let me see
yeah quick clarifying question yeah on
that diagram if you were to take one of
the paths in that Square circuit yeah
and links in it by half of wavelengths
yeah change the situation and now all
the photons would end up it would so a
phase is basically the path length right
phase is not just because it's
reflection versus normal reflection it
also takes the it's a letter yeah so
that's why that's why I mentioned
earlier that in this in this particular
configuration when the two patterns are
exactly equal you get constructive
interference at D 1 and destructive at D
2 but you can mess with if you if you
for instance if you put something here
that you know tune the path length
varied the path length you know from 0
to half a wavelength and back to 0 the
counts would keep switching so yeah so
you could change one of the paths so
that all of the photons go to d2 and
none go to d1 and anything in between
yeah absolutely
in fact that when they do the
experiments when they're trying to see
the interference that's what they're
doing there they don't always stick to
equal path lines they're constantly
varying the phase in one of the paths so
that you get the counts back and forth
and then you see how it's swinging so
the the key thing about this particular
configuration it can be done as you can
see on an optical bench and then it
allows you to do some really amazing
experiments and one of the one of the
things as a writer that you're looking
for always when you're trying to tell
these stories is you're trying to see
where to start
you know the storytelling because now
quantum mechanics is you know it's a
hundred plus year old field there are
lots of places in which you can start
telling your story and most of the
popular science books tend to start
really at the very beginning because the
very beginning is extremely intense and
wonderful you know we have Einstein and
Bohr and all these people arguing and
Heisenberg having sleepless nights and
coming up with this matrix mechanics and
Schrodinger really upset at Heisenberg
with wave mechanics all of these things
they're wonderful stories they've been
told over and over again right so I
wanted to find a way in which I could
focus the reader's attention on this
experiment what is it about this one
experiment that makes you you know that
you would want to read this particular
story this particular way of looking at
quantum mechanics and I and again as a
writer and reporter you're constantly
kind of tuned to looking for ways to
begin your story ways to end your story
etc and it was while I was visiting a
researcher in at the Perimeter Institute
in Ontario Canada you know as usual as
it was with almost all the quantum
physicists I met we would start the
discussion and he just jumped up to his
blackboard and started drawing equations
and you know diagrams and I must have
looked just as befuddled as I was with
each one of them and he realized okay I
have to reset the discussion he said
okay let me start by telling you
something imagine there's a factory that
makes bombs right so as soon as I heard
that I woke up and and then I want to
tell you this particular so this is how
the book begins the book begins by
asking the reader to imagine a factory
that's making bombs this is a puzzle
that was that's called the alert survive
man bomb puzzle after two Israeli
physicists who came up with it and it's
it's quite amazing it's so think about a
factory that makes bombs with triggers
that are so sensitive that even a single
particle of light a single photon of
light falling on the trigger will
detonate the ball the problem is that
the factory which is ostensibly
supplying these bombs to whoever wants
them also makes bombs without triggers
the duds right and your task is to
figure out how to sort the duds from the
live bombs classically with classical
physics you can't do this you have to
look at something to figure out whether
and even the act of looking with one
photon doesn't matter whether it's an
x-ray photon if you're trying to do it
in the dark some photon right it will
explode so you can't look at the thing
how do you sort out the bad from the
good we're allowed one concession we are
allowed
to explore some bombs in the process of
trying to at least find a sample of good
bombs that can be then shipped right and
when I was talking to the physicist his
name is Lucy and Hardy he also put the
good and bad in quotation marks saying
you might have a different moral
perspective on which I agree so this is
not to say anything about them
you know morality of these bombs so how
do you start sorting out the good back
bones from the back bones without
looking at them right and it can
actually be done using this setup right
it can actually be done using this setup
this is it oh so I didn't tell you why
this is a double slit experiment because
I should I should mention this so this
particular configuration is a very
special case of the double stood
experiment it's picking out if you go
back to this screen here it's picking
out all of those regions on the screen
where the the the phase difference
between the wave going from one slit and
the other slit is exactly equal and
where it's up 180 degrees out of phase
so that kind of represents a one
dimensional view of what's happening on
that 2d screen right you're picking out
all those points so d1 represents all
those points where the phase difference
on that screen is zero and d2 is
representing all those points on the
screen where the phase difference is 180
degrees right so this is a double slit
experiment but a very very you know
simple and and it's actually very lovely
to do on an optical bench okay so we can
we can solve this bomb puzzle using this
and how do you do that let me just do
one small thing which is to put a block
in one of the paths now when you send
10,000 photons what happens oddly is
that
only 5,000 get to the second beams later
the photons that are sensibly are going
through this path get blocked so only
5,000 make it here but off to 5,000 that
make it here remember without this block
all of them would have gone to d1 but
with this block now the 5,000 that come
here half go to d2 half go to d1 and the
reason is that you have to think of it
you have to think again of wave
functions the wave function is going
like that and that gets blocked it
doesn't go any further this component of
the wave function goes all the way here
doesn't meet anything else to interfere
with and half of it goes this way half
of it goes this way so essentially you
ended up with a wave function with half
the amplitude going this way half going
this way and you know so the
probabilities are 50/50 but of the of
the 10000 photons you sent in here 5,000
got block of the 5,000 that went this
way you got 50/50 split
so in this weird configuration with one
arm blocked you will see some photons
ending up at d2 if this wasn't there
there will be no photon at d2 right so
now we can tackle the BOM puzzle now
imagine this is a bomb placed right next
to the interferometer arm it has no
trigger this is one of the duds right so
if you and our task is to find life
bombs without triggers without looking
at them so now if you send 10,000
photons into this beam splitter nothing
it's no different I mean there's nothing
obstructing the path the bomb doesn't
have a trigger so you should all the
photons should go to d1 right so if you
send if you place one of these bombs
let's say you're doing this in a
darkroom with robots so you can handle
them and they don't explode for some
reason so you can put one next to the
interferometer like this so this is
called a you know this this setup is
called a Mach Zehnder interferometer so
now if you send you know million photons
and all of them end up at d1 it's very
very likely that the bomb you place next
to the interferometer is a dud
right but if you had a bomb with the
trigger which was obstructing the path
one of the paths now something very
interesting happens this is acting like
a detector it's acting like the block
you put
- one of the paths right half the time
the photons whoops half the time the
photon is going to take this path it's
going to meet the bomb the trigger and
the whole thing will explode you
reconstruct your interferometer start
all over again right and let's assume
that each time it goes this way you're
going to blow it up but half the time
the photon is going to take this path
and it's going to come here and then
half the time it's going to go to d1
that's inconclusive d1 could also happen
if there's a dud but if the photon goes
this way which it will because there is
no interference happening this path is
blocked by the bomb you will get some
photons going to d2 and the moment of
photon goes to d2 you know there is a
live bomb here with the trigger
obstructing your interferometer but you
have not interacted with it because if
you had interacted with it it would have
blown up right so this raises a profound
question you know you have knowledge
about something without having
interacted with it what interacted with
it some quantum physicists will argue
it's a wavefunction that interacted with
it this is proof that the wavefunction
is real right this is not a resolved
debate about the status of the
wavefunction is the wavefunction
something real in the world or is it
just a mathematical abstraction that we
use to understand how quantum systems
behave this is something called
interaction free measurements and if
this all seems like a little you know
esoteric as if oh this is just thortex
well this was a thought experiment but
these experiments have been done with
photons in the lab with you know
specialized configurations and this has
been tested this happens right so you
you know the clarifying question yeah on
the nature of that trigger yes what we
have to make quite clear that the dot
does not have any trigger at all it's
not like it has a trigger but the
electrical wire from that trigger to the
bomb yes it's a physical obstruction
yeah I should have made that clear so
the dot is simply a bomb without a
trigger if it has a trigger it's an
extremely sensitive trigger yeah so and
and of course you're placing it so that
you know it exactly obstructs the path
right and it's a photon so yeah this is
all thought experiment so bear with me
yeah but the point to be made here is
that this configuration of a double slit
experiment actually picks out
something without interacting with it
right so this this becomes a way of
understanding or at least raising the
question about the status of the wave
function what is the wave function right
so you can see that the double set
experiment even the very minimal stuff
that I've shown you already allows you
as a pedagogical tool you've used we now
use the term real several times yes I've
always been curious about what does it
what do these physicists mean when they
say this is real this is really a
mathematical abstraction so in this in
this way the way I'm using it is it's
basically the kind of debate that
Einstein was having with Bohr about
realism so to Einstein a physical theory
should be capturing the real world which
exists independent of you or I or any
observation looking for it it's just
there and our physical theories are
capturing that reality so there should
be variables in the theory that tell us
what's out there right whereas so real
in that context so something that's real
independent of an observer or an
observation and we just discover what's
out there on that note my seem to
discover a certain bias when you talk
about the photons are particle and you
supply that story or when you talk about
it as the wave bundle then that's the
mathematical abstraction but you could
turn this around okay and and for me and
and the photon you know the photon is a
quantum system you know it's it's
described by a quantum state and the
quantum state and that's where we get
down to this issue of is the quantum
state describing something real that so
in quantum mechanics there is no way to
describe the trajectory of a photon as
it goes from here to there there is no
variable there are no sets of variables
that capture the position and momentum
at every point as the photon travels
from here to there right you can't do
that you it has a position only upon
observation so it becomes real so to say
upon observation it has a definite
position the moment
it's observed but until it's observed
you can only talk probabilistically
about where it might be so so I'm
talking about
realism in that context this is the
theory capturing something that so if
you interpret standard quantum mechanics
so standard quantum mechanics is
basically a lot of lovely mathematics
that allows you to make predictions
about the outcomes of experiments you
might do and these predictions happen to
be probabilistic and and they're very
accurate and all of that but then you
start interpreting as to what the
mathematics is and the Copenhagen
interpretation which is kind of a lose
name for a whole bunch of different
things and one of one of the things that
the Copenhagen interpretation will say
is that you can't talk off the photon as
being real until you've absorbed it so
in that sense it's an anti realist
interpretation but now again it's very
divisive the field not everyone will
agree that that's what the Copenhagen
interpretation says so these debates go
on and on and on no one's quite sure
what Bohr was saying anyway all the time
so you know it's very hard to kind of
pin down any one person's philosophy on
this but my point in the book was to
make it clear to the reader that look
these distinctions are there we don't
understand them and these are the tools
to understand the philosophical debates
not answer them because the debates have
not been resolved yet right so and and
for the issue of quantum superposition
whether I brought this up earlier what
what is quantum superposition it's a
weird thing all we are saying is that
the wavefunction exists in you know it
takes both paths and that seems to imply
that the photon exists in the
superposition of going through one path
and the other path but is it really
going through both paths not really is
it going through one path and not the
other not really is it going through
neither not really we really don't know
that's the whole essence of it we don't
we can't say anything about what the
photon exactly is doing given the
mathematics right now someone like
Einstein will say well that's because
the mathematics is incomplete that there
has there have to be other variables
that capture what the photon is doing
and we just don't have them and there is
a hidden reality that needs to be
captured by the mathematics and there
have been attempts to do so right so the
point I'm trying to make here is that
just
simple experiment allows you to
understand what physicists are saying
when they say oh the photon is in a
quantum superposition of taking both
paths it's math it's a mathematical way
of saying the wave function goes splits
and goes in two ways but that's not the
same as saying the photon is going to
both paths complementarity and wave
particle duality this is this was Niels
Bohr's idea that you know Nature has
particle nature and our reality has
particle nature and wave nature and you
can only observe one or the other and
what you observe depends on what you are
looking to see so if you if your
experiment is designed your experiment
is designed to look for the particle
nature which this configuration of the
interferometer without this second wave
splitter is doing then you will see the
particle nature which is half of them go
one way half of them so the you can you
can talk of the photon taking one path
or the other path you can talk of it as
a particle but if you put the second
beam splitter in this entire
configuration now he's looking for its
wave nature and you will see it's wave
nature and you can't you know you you
one is to the exclusion of the other
this is now again debated there are
experiments which are showing you can
see 30% wave 70% particle it gets very
very hairy but the point is that you
know again you can you can look at the
simple experiment and understand what
somebody like Bohr was going on about
and determinism but versus non
deterministic problem clear to you by
now that you can only talk of things
happening at the quantum level in
probabilistic terms you can't be you
know so the outcome of an experiment you
can only assign probabilities to the
outcome
you cannot deterministically say exactly
what's going to happen right there might
be multiple outcomes for the same thing
and they will all have different
probabilities so any given instance of
that experiment you will see one of
those outcomes you cannot
deterministically see exactly what will
happen the probabilities get borne out
when you do the same experiment a number
of times so again all of these
conceptual issues can be understood the
the biggest thing that this throws up is
something called the measurement problem
which has to do with the collapse of the
wavefunction and let me for this go back
to that
this figure here so if you think of this
wave that's being represented here not
as the way of wave of light but the wave
function that has gone through both
slits and it has expanded on the other
side interfere and it hits the
photographic plate then at the
photographic plate standard quantum
mechanics says that it's the act of
measurement that causes the collapse of
the wave function because at the plane
of the photographic plate the wave
function is spread out which means that
if you were to calculate the
probabilities of where you might find
the photon you will have nonzero
probabilities in many places all of
those places which represent
constructive interference there will be
nonzero probabilities right but then the
wave function encounters the
photographic plate and standard quantum
mechanics says that the act of measuring
the act of observation is the thing that
collapses the wave function such that it
goes from being spread out to being
peaked or localized the photon appears
in one place it could appeared in any
one of those places where the
probability was nonzero but it appears
at one place right now this kind of
language has been used to argue that the
observer is central to quantum mechanics
right
but is it really right this is this is
so and the the language has been used to
say that the measurement the observer
causes the collapse of the wavefunction
the mathematics does not define anywhere
what a measurement is okay it see the
Copenhagen interpretation simply divides
the world into quantum and classical and
the classical world is the one making
the observation on the quantum world but
it doesn't say what a classical world is
it doesn't say where is the transition
from the quantum to the classical how
big does the measuring device have to be
in order for it to collapse the wave
function right none of those things are
there in the math is just some by dicta
that it said oh the measure there's the
there's the quantum system and there's
the measuring apparatus measuring
apparatus collapses the wavefunction
right given that it's not dead when you
kind of run this argument through in
your head you end up with things like
Schrodinger's cat being dead and alive
at the same time etcetera etcetera it's
it's so and it has often been used to
argue for the primacy of human
consciousness as a way of collapsing the
wavefunction but the point I made in the
book is that the experiment and the math
actually says nothing about human
consciousness right those are just
things we make up and it actually
becomes fodder for talking about quantum
mechanics in all ways and the reality is
that the the math is just making
probabilistic predictions about the
outcomes of experiments and then there
are interpretations there is a central
axiom in quantum mechanics which says
measurements causes collapse but it
doesn't define what the measurement is
so for a lot of people working in the
foundations of quantum mechanics this is
a huge issue and it's called the
measurement problem it's related to the
collapse of the wavefunction so a lot of
the other alternative interpretations
and alternative theories that are trying
to solve this measurement problem and by
solving the measurement problem the idea
is to come up with a theory that does
not depend on a measurement for the
wavefunction to collapse it does not
depend on an observer right can it be
something that happens and we as
observers as measuring devices just
discover what has happened and so those
altered alternative theories exist there
are other questions that come up realism
versus non realism we've been discussing
it so there are theories you can argue
that standard quantum
mechanics is non-realistic you know
that's an extreme interpretation but
there are people who will say that there
are realistic versions of quantum
mechanics not you can't call it quantum
mechanics but for I'll mention it in a
bit but there are other alternative
theories that are realist that says for
instance that a photon exists at all
times and it has a definite position and
it's a particle with a definite position
and momentum at all times and that's a
realist theory unlike standard quantum
mechanics the wavefunction questions
about the wavefunction come up which you
can ask in the context of the double
slit experiment is it epistemic in the
sense that is it just representing our
knowledge about the quantum world or is
it ontological or ontic is it actually
something real if it is something real
then it's quite a bizarre thing because
the wavefunction moves not in
three-dimensional space but in in a
multi-dimensional configuration space it
is so if there are if there are n
particles then the dimensionality of the
configuration space is 3 times n so it's
a massively you know so if you take 10
to the I don't know how many particles
that are in the universe to the
wavefunction for that would be in some
really really massively hyper
dimensional space so it's moving around
in this mathematical space and its value
is a complex number so what on earth is
real about it
we have no idea so but there are very
very strong arguments for to be made
about the wavefunction being something
real if it is something real then it
leads to other issues like entanglement
and nonlocality like if if the
wavefunction is something real and it
has spread out and you make a
measurement and the wavefunction
collapses at one point it its value
Peaks at one point then Einstein was the
first to point out the problem with this
is at the moment it Peaks at one point
and if you consider this wavefunction to
be real then it has disappeared from all
other points in space-time and this
wavefunction could have been spread out
you know as much as you want and one act
of measurement at one point collapses it
and it's disappeared in value its value
has gone to zero everywhere else that's
a very non-local behavior it's it's
there's a notion of simultaneity built
into the collapse which completely
countered
special relativity there is no notion of
simultaneity in special relativity so
you can see why Einstein was so terribly
bothered by this right but so you know
so you can start explaining notions of
entanglement of nonlocality using this
one experiment you can also talk about
the various interpretations Copenhagen I
mentioned that so far this the probably
the strongest alternative to that well I
shouldn't say strongest because
depending on who you talk to they'll
disagree or agree but there's de
broglie-bohm theory which says that
nature is both wave and particle in the
simplest way to understand this in the
context of the double slit is you shoot
a photon at the double slit it will go
as a single particle through one slit or
the other but it's being guided by a
pilot wave the pilot wave is the one
that hits both slits interferes on the
other side and then guides the particle
to one of the places of constructive
interference so nature is both particle
and wave and in this case the wave
function is real except that it moves
around in this weird configuration space
right and the particle is real so this
is a realist theory it's also
deterministic and but it's extremely
non-local because there's only one wave
function and all particles are
interacting with this wave function so
anytime the wave function changes all
the particles in the universe are
instantaneously affected by it so
something you do here could affect a
particle on Andromeda instantly
according to the theory right so you can
see why that can create other kinds of
problems so but that's a very formidable
sort of alternative to standard quantum
theory there are so-called collapse
theories collapse theories are basically
remember that the big conceptual problem
with standard quantum mechanics is the
notion of collapse like what causes
collapse why should we make measurement
the centerpiece of the theory even when
you can't even define what a measurement
is so the collapse theories are
basically saying that collapse happens
stochastically it happens randomly
throughout you know so if there's a
wavefunction it's almost like
multiplying this wavefunction with
something that is peaked at one point
and it's it ends up collapsing to that
location at that location but that is
random and the mathematics has built
into it the properties that it needs in
order to rep
empirical data that we have from
experiments so it will it will replicate
exactly the predictions of standard
quantum mechanics except that it is not
dependent on the observer and the
wavefunction is real so all these things
are slightly different right there's of
course the many-worlds interpretation
which which boggles your mind in other
ways so what this says is that when the
wavefunction splits and goes through two
slits and if these two wave functions
don't are not brought back again to
interfere they eventually will interact
with the individual environments and
they will become what's called d
coherent they can't interfere any
further once they can't interfere any
further they are in separate universes
so each time you split the wave function
so that and and the decohere to the
point that they can't be made to
interfere again you are now in separate
universes so every time a wavefunction
and if you if you think this makes no
sense there is actually a company in
Geneva that will split the universe for
you if you have if you have an iphone
you can download an app called the
universe splitter and if you have a
decision to make
say you know should I do this or
shouldn't I do this just ask the
universe splitter it sends a command to
Geneva all that thing in Geneva does it
it sends a photon through a beam
splitter and and it'll it will send you
back the reply saying your photon went
through this arm of the and you can you
can see in your app saying okay do
whatever you choose to do except that in
another universe you've got the opposite
answer so you can rest easy that in
another universe you've done the other
thing there's also something called
quantum Bay Zionism which is quite
interesting in the sense that it's very
small coterie of people pursuing it but
the idea there is that the wave function
that we've been talking about until now
the wave function has been ascribed to
the particle right it's basically we're
saying that the wave function describes
the quantum state of an electron or some
quantum system in quantum Bayesian ISM
the wave function is simply in your head
it has nothing to do with the real world
make of that what you may but it has its
own logic behind it and it works in
certain ways it's still being worked out
but so these are
kind of the major categories of
interpretations that are trying to solve
essentially the the measurement problem
the collapse problem right and trying to
come up with theories that are saying
something about what's out there and not
just being an instrumentalist tool to
make predictions of our outcomes of
experiments so you can see how one
single experiment can take you through
the entire length and breadth of quantum
mechanics and that's what sort of I
ended up doing in that book yeah well
thank you very much
[Applause]
so I'll start question from the
beginning you said that lists be very
little the few last few decades to
radically change quantum physics but for
many of us in this room quantum
computing was a very big development
question about what yeah yeah so I was
thinking more in terms of the
foundations of quantum mechanics
conceptually has anything so quantum
computation I would argue that is using
standard quantum mechanics and you know
taking it in a certain direction but in
terms of actually understanding what
quantum theory is saying about reality
that nothing so the big thing that has
changed is probably all of the
experiments that were done to test
nonlocality so all the bells bells test
well I was wondering about video you
were also trying to reach an audience
and many more people could probably be
reached by alluding to this connection
to the I would agree yes yeah I kept
away from that because this was a very
focused book on the experiment but yeah
I would very much agree with you that
quantum computation has it raises
actually very profound questions about
exactly these things because now you're
using these conceptual ideas that come
from standard quantum mechanics with the
sort of instrumentalist approach and are
able to do these things and that's
suggesting that some of these things
that are being claimed by standard
quantum mechanics
actually happening and I I don't know
how to analyze that from the point of
view but yes that would be a way to get
more people involved in some issues even
the mathematics not just interface but
so when you think about mechanically so
in this in this particular case what I
did you know I and so in the book I talk
about multi particle particle
entanglement remember I mentioned
somewhere in the middle that if you had
a way in which you could figure out
which Slater particle is going through
without destroying it if you just
collected information about which Slater
particle is going through then you could
potentially you know sort of you would
essentially mess up the interference
pattern but how do you do it you you
know with a with a photon you can't
measure it to see which litter is going
through without destroying it and the
way you do it is by using entangled
pairs of photons so you send one of the
entangled pair into the beam splitter
and the beam splitter is designed it's
called a polarizing beam splitter where
if the photon is horizontally polarized
it takes one path if it's vertically
polarized it takes another path right
and you have the other photon with you
which is now entangled with the photon
that went into the beam splitter so if
you did a polarization measurement on
the pair that you have you would
instantly know what happened to the
other one so by so if you if you make
measurements on the entangled partner
say in the horizontal basis and found it
to be horizontal then you know that the
photon that went into the Venus we took
one path and not the other but if you if
you made a measurement in this this is
getting into kind of details about
polarization measurements but if you
were to measure the polarization of the
entangled partner that you have in a way
where you can't tell whether it's
horizontal or
article then you you kind of erase that
information that you had and the photon
that goes through the second the beam
splitter will act like a wave it it'll
interfere so so yeah I mean and in order
to understand entanglement you have to
talk about the very first bell
experiment and all that so which I do in
the book it's it's basically set up to
talk about multi particle multi particle
entanglement yeah so I've been worrying
about these kind of issues for almost
sixty years now so involved enough to
offer another interpretation philosophy
which esif kept me sane in the in the
wealth of possible different
interpretations I think it all started
when as a high school student I write
that Heisenberg said that kind of
answers you get from experiments depends
on what questions you ask did you ask
the photon or your particle the fotomat
said yeah sometimes I behave like a
particle and if you ask the photon are
you late yeah sometimes I paid like a
way so since then I have thought scaled
back and I don't think that scientists
really are healthier to get the truth
and find out what's real what I this do
is they make a model of what they think
describes that very very complicated
world out there and you judge a model my
house ability is primarily and then how
much predictive power it has and that
gets rid of a lot of these and kind of
fuzzy instances because let's assume
that a photon is something much much
more complicated than either leaf or a
particle whatever may be some wave might
thing that spreads through the whole
universe maybe not all of that then our
quantum mechanical wave function becomes
a very very simplistic abstraction of
something like that and it basically
tells us what you know about the fall
over there and we certainly know exactly
where the photon is and the wave
function collapses well that's our
primitive model it doesn't mean that
that's what's really happening
and so yeah so you're you're you are a
lady and your best money that you'll
think of some of these deep
philosophical problem sort of go away to
true so the the instrumentalists would
argue exactly like you arguing that they
would say that let's just you know in
fact that's how quantum mechanics is
practiced without worrying about this
physical you know interpretations of
what's happening at the level of
physical reality right certainly but
there are there have been physicists
including Einstein who wasn't happy with
that you know his point his point was
that our theories about in physics
should be actually about understanding
what is real and we still don't quite
know when it comes to quantum reality
what to make of what the theory is
saying about the nature of reality and
you can find enough people who will take
that position even now and all of the
alternative approaches are about that
they're you know you you're very right
that you know that's one way in which
you can just say those philosophical
issues go away because quantum mechanics
is a fabulously successful theory I
forget the decimal digits to which it
has been verified but I think you know
are things that have been verified to
fourteen decimal digits it's really the
most accurate theory out there but it
still doesn't tell us for those people
who really worried about this and there
are physicists who worried about this it
still doesn't tell us about what really
is real and even that I'm putting that
in courts because there's argument about
what that even means
yes I'm just wondering whether you will
say that something is classical this
time it's really time I don't even want
to go anywhere near it
yeah well quantum mechanics standard
quantum mechanics time flows one way and
there are time symmetric formulations of
I don't deal with it in this book at all
the only place where I point out is this
the only place where I point out the
notion of time getting into trouble
getting us into trouble is with this
configuration so this is if you switch
between these two configurations you get
to do what's called wheelers delayed
choice experiment right so how are we
running out of time oh my god so I'm
happy to stop or go on shall I talk
about this one little thing okay I
didn't even see that so this is you know
a Mach Zehnder interferometer where you
are choosing to see the wave nature this
is the configuration where you're
choosing to see the particle nature
right so what John Wheeler suggested
that what if we let the proton enter the
set up without the second beam splitter
in place let it enter now if you are
saying that the photon has some
intrinsic nature right its intrinsic
nature in this case should be let's say
that of a particle it's going to go in
one path or the other path and then just
before it hits that intersection you
somehow insert the second beam splitter
right now what's the photon to do right
it turns out it acts like a wave because
it encounters the second beam but then
just before it encountered that you were
ascribing to the photon an intrinsic
nature which means it has to go back in
time and undo its intrinsic nature and
come back into the apparatus as a wave
so when you start thinking in terms of
time this really messes you up
or if you think in terms of the photon
having an intrinsic reality before you
detect it right so time becomes a messy
messy issue here I haven't I stayed away
from crime entirely in this book
Thank You vice thank you very much
[Applause]